well it is about time to hit the slope
safety precautions are in place at lee
canyon ski
area with the season getting off to a
fresh start kids are on their christmas
break now
it's official so winter reservations
have been pouring in eight news now
reporter madison kimbrough
headed up to the mountain and she brings
us this story
four inches of snow fell thursday night
making reservations for the weekend
skyrocket at lee canyon
skiers and snowboarders enjoying this
winter wonderland while maintaining
distance
it's a different year at the ski resort
with many precautions in place
i spoke to some snow enthusiasts about
the changes leaking in their hand
they're handling it very well
with the hand sanitizer requiring the
mask and just you know the social
distancing
i think it's it's pretty safe here it's
tough i'm glad that they could stay open
especially like during this time and i'm
glad that i see everybody's wearing
their mask and everybody's being safe i
think that people definitely know that
there's a pandemic going on and they
want a social distance
jim seeley marketing director at lee
canyon acknowledges the fact that during
these winter months
is when we need to be the safest parking
reservations
that all guests have to make you know
making sure that they have
a lift ticket or their season pass
holder to come up here
so you know we're controlling our
capacity guests and employees
are wearing masks you know we're
promoting physical distancing
uh you know obviously um you know like
when going on the chair lift it's
going on the chairlift with who you came
up with only another extremely important
factor is making sure their dining area
is sanitized and limited to 25 percent
capacity
reporting in lee canyon madison
kimbrough 8 news now